yo yo julio hey man check this out man
you see the message above right here bro
come on bro come by with me bro hey you
know what i'm good for you know all them
talks we'll be having you know i'm
saying bro you know what i'm good for
bro you know i got your back
like trust me bro if you want to carry
the load you can carry it
but if you get tired you know
differently you know i carry you bro
another thing you know i'm not giving my
number up
i said i would i tried to get number one
they said i can't so you're gonna have
to rock number eight you already know
all of this but hey just come mess with
your boy man hey real talk man hey we
waiting on you over here you say you
want to win right we just need a couple
more pieces hey trust me
hey come by with me man
that's aj brown making the case for
julio jones to join the tennessee titans
and again it's not up to him but as
you've said titan's one of the teams
that julio jones is looking at let's
draft
the teams where we think julio jones
will be playing in
2021 a quick trivia question for chris
prior to 2020 julio jones had six
straight seasons with 1300 receiving
yards a streak that's tied for most in
nfl history with what other receiver
hint this receiver won a super bowl and
made an all-decade team but he has yet
to make it to the hall of fame wow okay
so he's yet to make six straight 1300
yard seasons man six straight 1300 yard
season so i'm i want to lean on somebody
from this this this past decade but
there there definitely could be somebody
there in the 2000s that i'm not thinking
of either
oh man all right i'm going to go with
antonio brown even though i don't i
don't know yeah man what would it would
i help would i help if i told you well
he he hasn't well he has won a super
bowl now so that's what kind of threw me
off a little
would it help if i say he has a jacked
up finger
oh it was tori holt huh yes damn it i i
i thought of the rams guys i did i'm not
not gonna lie that would have been my
next guess it would have i just i wasn't
100 sure there damn it all right
go ahead all right uh i i'm gonna go
with the patriots it feels like that
bill belichick
just waiting for the right opportunity
to pounce with an offer you can't refuse
you got five seconds to take it do it
now take it now now now now and he's
gonna end up getting julio jones yeah i
don't i don't see that as being crazy i
could see that you know and again
takes pressure
off of cam newton the offense in a lot
of ways and even for the future and mac
jones you know if he's going to take
over two years from now you got that
type of thing but julio jones is a
difference maker and yeah the patriots
are they're all in so i i wouldn't be
shocked with that i'll go with the
tennessee titans as my first one
i think there's a real need there i
think that's a real fit as far as just
like hey
his style of play how it's going to fit
that offense there in tennessee he is
similar to aj brown they would have the
all muscle team that's for sure i mean
pecks and biceps and you know six packs
and everything like that i mean that's
freak show central right there between
those two guys but i think it makes a
lot of sense and of course the titans
are a very good football team certainly
can be in that super bowl conversation
and this would help that help that out a
lot with julio
aj brown said that julio jones would
have to change his number that he's not
giving up number 11. i have a feeling
that if julio wants number 11 and he
ends up with the titans
rock paper scissors i think julio is
going to get number 11. and i think aj
brown probably knows that deep down if
that's how it goes down all right next
one for me and this is a team that we've
talked about a few times and i could see
chris ballard the gem of the colts being
willing to do it on his terms on his
terms it would require the patriots to
not be seriously interested the titans
to not be seriously interested because
if he can steal julio jones chris
ballard will and julio jones would
become a member of the colts yeah i i
i hear you there i do i mean that's
that's a good one i think it makes a lot
of sense you know for for the
indianapolis colts i really do i mean
they're as we've talked about really
good football team have it all i think
the big thing is just like one more
difference maker maybe on either side of
the ball and i think they're hoping they
got that with the quitty pay draft pick
in the first round and now if they could
get one guy on the offense just to be a
little bit of a a pressure taker offer
type guy uh that would make sense so
that's a good pick by you all the way
i'm with you with the colts i in fact i
would think they're maybe you know in
the leader house as far as uh
teams that'd be looking for him did you
just say leaderhouse to throw me off the
scent of pressure taker offer no no i do
leader out leader house out there to be
funny pressure taker offer i couldn't
think of a proper thing so i just added
the er to the end okay i don't know i
couldn't think of it all right so all
right now this is where it gets a little
nitty-gritty here i mean
for sake of the draft and fun i mean
according i'm gonna say green bay i mean
that's what i want i don't know if it's
very realistic at this point
but like you've said it's a great way to
mend fences there with aaron rodgers and
maybe you know get him to feel a little
bit better uh and again yeah they're a
team that's legit and they are one of
those teams like the colts we just
talked about where i just want to go
it just can't always be rogers having to
throw the perfect ball into a tight
window you know 12 14 yards down the
field just every now and then you'd like
to see can he throw a slant the guy
break a big play or just have a go route
the guy can beat the guy deep down the
field and we can throw it to him you
know that doesn't exist there in green
bay so
uh i'll say julia to green bay for my
second one
yeah and and and i agree with you it's
unrealistic because i don't think the
packers are going to do it they created
some cap space today by restructuring
some guy's contract not nearly enough
not even close to what they're going to
need they're going to need to do rogers
and devonte adams contracts to create
the cap space necessary to trade for
julio jones i don't think they're
inclined to do it my next team i don't
think they're inclined to do it either
but i'm going to go ahead and say the
seahawks because hey i thought about it
yeah you you want to have some say and
he's been politicking for guys like
antonio brown and he wanted josh gordon
and hey julio jones with tyler lockett
and dk metcalf good lord you want the
offense to run through russell wilson
you give him julio jones the offense is
running through russell wilson they
won't do it but if i'm russell wilson
i'm i'm doing everything i can to think
of how i can get someone's attention
and say to them hey you want to make me
happy you want me to be here this is the
kind of stuff you need to be doing guys
oh that that would be uh that would be
fun to watch i mean i would think
they're going to be a big like three
receiver team you know with the the
offensive coordinator coming from the
rams that's what they do
so i i they did cross my mind they did a
similar situation like you talk we talk
about with rogers it could be a way to
maybe it soothes over russell wilson and
he's like okay hey the hell with it i'll
stay here um all right last one here and
i'm going to go with the baltimore
ravens i am going with baltimore i think
there's still even even after they
drafted a guy
i'm still going to go with it i am you
know i just
he's he's a rookie they're in the super
bowl window right now
we know they can run the football you
had a guy with julio and hollywood brown
and rashad bateman wow that's going to
put some people in some binds as far as
what to do and how to defend lamar
jackson on that offense so uh i'll throw
that out there again i don't know if
that's really realistic we haven't heard
a ton of teams that are associated with
getting in the mix with julio jones but
i can see them maybe being one of those
teams that does that
yeah i agree with you and uh we'll see
how it plays out next wednesday is when
it can be official but anytime between
now and then we can hear
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports